oil and water do not mix but politics
and oil bond very well there is no
official transcript of the conversation
between the US president and the Saudi
Crown Prince which resulted in Saudi
Arabia's latest oil production cut
report suggests President Donald Trump
told Mohammed bin Salman that US forces
stationed in the kingdom could be
withdrawn if Saudi Arabia did not stop
flooding the market with cheap crude
within days Riyadh announced production
cuts and ended its oil price war with
Russia OPEC in g20 members including
Quaid's in no way have already announced
cuts and output but questions still
remain over compliance the US president
has taken credit for the nearly 10
million barrel cut by oil producers
which comes into effect on Friday I
think I got them to cut maybe
[Music]
well they say 10 they say 10 million but
I think it's 15 million barrels I even
heard 20 million Saudi Arabia and
Russia's failure to agree on price
stabilization led to a 31-day price war
which has resulted in a massive
oversupply of crude that combined with a
coronavirus shutdown of the world's
major economies provided a perfect storm
for the first time in history traders
were paying to get rid of oil stocks
after storage ran out and US crude
futures dipped to a record - $40 a
barrel the International Energy Agency
estimates global storage capacity could
be full by mid-june with a powerful
lobby and nearly a million US
hydrocarbon sector jobs at stake it's
now an issue of national security for
the United States we're also exploring
potentially having the ability to store
another several hundred million barrels
so we're looking at lots of different
options were in touch with lots of
people around the world and the
president is determined that we protect
the national security interest and the
job with flights grounded no one driving
and factories closed analysts estimate
the demand gap is in excess of 30
million barrels even though some
restrictions are slowly being lifted the
energy market is gloomy on positive
projections international oil price is
estimated to average around 31
dollars a barrel while the u.s. price is
expected below $20 a drop of 60%
compared to last year major firms such
as Royal Dutch Shell are readjusting
shell cut its dividend for the first
time since World War two no way
Western Europe's biggest oil and natural
gas producer wants to ease tax rules for
oil firms to prevent a drop in
investment there is the short term
benefit for oil consumers the european
central bank says inflation has declined
due to the sharp fall in oil prices but
slowing growth global job losses and
declining industry coupled with falling
oil production doesn't bode well for the
global economy sama bin zayed al Jazeera